we have a major update from all of our
expert scientists
this is going to put us all at ease
finally get the country moving again
joe biden's covid advisor promises us
that we just have to lock down the
country for
another four to six weeks and then four
to six weeks that we're gonna lock down
we're gonna stay in our pods
we're not gonna go outside no one's
gonna work and then in four to six weeks
then we will return from this pandemic
i would remind everybody it is now 241
days
since the federal government told us
that we had 15 days to slow the spread
that's the science you got to trust the
science even when the science changes
its mind
every single day that's what you can
look forward to if joe biden wins the
race
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from jacob
who says oh this is a quote this is a
quote from joe biden
presidential candidate who might
consider himself the president-elect
we have put together i think the most
extensive and inclusive
voter fraud organization in the history
of american politics that might be the
one time joe biden has told the truth
i think we found the one that's a
freudian slip which of course is where
you say one thing but mean your mother
joe biden bragged about this now
people came out and said no no joe biden
what he really meant
was that it's the best voter fraud
uh fighting organization or the the most
anti-voter fraud well that's not what he
said
and the more we learn out of
philadelphia the more we learn out of
pittsburgh the more we learn at
arizona the more we learn out of georgia
the more we learn out of michigan
seems like joe might have been telling
the truth we'll get to all of those
states
in just a second
this election is going to be really
really close
regardless of who wins it if president
trump wins it if joe biden wins it
it's going to be a really really close
shave and if you want a close shave i
would strongly recommend
you check out harry's razors how is that
for a segway
i love harry's razors this is the best
razor
hands down that i've ever used they have
new sharper blades
those new sharper blades are the same
low price that harry's has always
brought you
two dollars a piece that is unbelievable
that does not make any
sense you can find harry's in the big
box drugstore near you or you can get
harry's online
which i would strongly recommend that's
what i do i never remember
to go out and buy new razors so in the
old days i would just use the same razor
for like
years at a time it was certainly a
health hazard speaking of public health
so go sign up you get this wonderful
german factory they've been honing razor
blades for 100 years
they source their steel from sweden and
they also have a 100
quality guarantee you're not going to
have any questions about them though
you're going to love harry's
best shave i've ever had available
wherever you shop
if you like to shop online harry's has a
great offer for the listeners right now
new u.s customers can redeem a harry's
trial set
at harrys.com knowles k-n-w-l-e-s you
will get a five blade razor
featuring their new sharper blades a
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
aloe and a travel cover to protect your
blade when you're on the go and i love
that travel cover because it's got
little holes in it so it can actually
kind of breathe it's just it's so great
harry's dot com slash knowles k-w-l-e-s
redeem your trial offer today
trust me you're not going to want to
miss out on that
that's just science you're not going to
want to miss out on a great that's just
we're told all the time about science
what what happened when our public
health experts like dr fauci for
instance told us not to wear masks don't
wear masks masks are bad for you if you
wear a mask you're being irresponsible
surgeon general of the united states
said the same thing and we were told
trust the science believe the science
as though the science was some deity
that we have to pay obeisance to
well then all those guys completely
changed their minds based on what based
on new studies we didn't get really new
studies
they changed their minds then you got to
believe the science there we were told
believe the science 15 days to slow the
spread flatten the curve
so that you don't overwhelm the hospital
system not find a cure not reduce the
number of cases
not even really reduce the number of
deaths just reduce the number of
unnecessary deaths if you were to
overwhelm the hospital system we never
came close to overwhelming the hospital
system
anywhere in the country including new
york they had the javits center they had
that hospital ship didn't need either of
them
same thing over in california didn't
need a great big success
right so the lockdowns are over by april
1st right
no way not a chance we're now 241
days in people are dying alone
people are not seeing their grandparents
now we're being told we're not allowed
to go home for thanksgiving
or if we do go home you can only have a
meal with 10 people
so if you know i've got some catholic
friends of mine some of them have just
10 kids or 11 kids or 12 kids so you
gotta
you got to pick your favorites you got
gotta send those other kids outside
they're not
maybe they can come for christmas we'll
see we'll see if president-elect
joe biden will let them more on him
in just a bit so there's one new machine
out of nebraska
which is it's an it's a new scientific
way to circumvent the lockdowns
it allows you to hug i can't even get
through it without laughing
it allows you to hug your relatives
by by reaching through a plastic
sheet and and in plastic wrapping your
plastic arms
around your beloved grandfather take a
[Music]
listen
[Music]
something kind of heartwarming because
you know that these grandparents haven't
seen their grandkids in however long
it's also very sad
this is great
this this is what not the virus has
reduced this to
this is what bad policies have reduced
us to this is
inhuman but you know i i have uh
friends i unfortunately haven't been
able to travel back to see my
grandparents in the last
whatever five or six months that this
has really been going on
but i have friends who have and in some
cases
the the parents didn't want to see them
they said i'm too afraid of the virus
but in most cases
the grandparents said come on in here
sonny this happened to a very good
friend of mine just a couple months ago
he said come on in here i know i'm 85
years old i know i'm at risk but you
know i'm going to die soon anyway and i
don't want to go without seeing my loved
ones
there have been petitions in nursing
there was a protest actually at a
nursing home
where people said the thing we look
forward to is getting hugs from our
relatives and you're taking that away
from us
you sick politicians
that question of whether or not you can
hug your grandparents that's not a
scientific question
maybe there's some increased risk to the
virus maybe the risk actually isn't
that large compared to other other
viruses that's sort of beside the point
there's a political question a
philosophical question
a theological question what are we here
for how are we to relate to one another
how are we to
relate to life how are we to relate to
death
it occurred to me yesterday that covid
is the single craziest thing to ever
happen in my lifetime
ever not the virus we've had plenty of
viruses in my lifetime
west nile ebola all those sort of things
swine flu
the loc the covid lockdowns that's the
craziest thing to happen in my lifetime
i tweeted this out and a number of
people said well what about 9 11 you
were alive for 9 11.
9 11 i guess was the most horrific thing
to happen in my lifetime
but that's different than crazy it's not
that it was so crazy so unusual so
unexpected so unprecedented there have
always been terrorist attacks
in history many of them have come from
islamic radicals there actually was
already a terror attack on the world
trade center in 1993
the people who did it told us their
justification for doing it so still
obviously horrific crazy is a different
thing
and the covid lockdowns are absolutely
crazy because there is no
reasoning behind it they change the
reasoning
every single day they extend it
indefinitely there is no end in sight no
matter what
these hack politicians tell you biden's
covet advisor says four to six weeks
a likely story i've heard that one
before to quote a former president
fool me once shame on you fooled me
twice the point is you ain't gonna fool
me again
that's the sort of science that we're
talking about here
it's just a power grab i am not going to
wear a mask at thanksgiving
i would encourage you all not to wear
masks on thanksgiving
i'm not making a scientific point i'm
not saying it's because
you know the sci the masks don't work
that well even though we've quoted
many epidemiologists for instance from
colombia we've quoted the cdc we've
quoted dr fauci himself saying that the
masks don't work that well that's not
the point i'm making
i'm not going to wear the mask because
the masks are disordered
they present a disordered view of the
world a disordered view
of germs a disordered view of society
and social relations
and they change what we are social
animals aristotle calls us the political
animal
they change that social nature of us
from looking at one another as fellow
human beings fellow citizens fellow
family members
to looking at each other as bags of
germs
that are going to destroy us that are
out to kill us
that only can be protected
by the government and by government
lockdowns i ain't gonna do it it's
political control in the name of science
now by the way
people have people have been asking me
since the beginning of covet some people
who are a little more
eccentric or excitable they've said
michael this is the end times
covid is it heralding the the end times
the antichrist
and the kovid stuff it's going to be the
mark of the beast
and i said you know that seems a little
that seems a little uh
extreme you know no one knows the day or
the hour not even the sun
but only the father knows it there so
i'm not going to presume to know that
but then i read stories like this and i
say gosh this i don't know maybe those
excitable people have a point
now that a vaccine is in the works it
looks like it's going to come out it was
announced just a couple days after the
election
conveniently now we're being told by
ticketmaster
ticketmaster may resume live events but
they're going to require you
to present a sort of passport to say
that you've had the vaccine
that's a very creepy position to be in
where in order to engage in commercial
activity you have to get a certain
vaccine we've never really had that in
america
now ticketmaster is saying perhaps you
can have a test and if you can prove
that you have the test
fine what is scientific about that
if i were to get the flu right now i'd
be at a much greater risk of dying right
depending on what conditions i've gotten
but younger people babies children
much higher risk from the flu which we
all tolerate
than from coronavirus
how come we don't require that you get
your flu shot maybe we soon will require
that you get your flu shot
that's again a political question
but it's all being passed off in science
the mayor of chicago
the failed state of chicago and the
failed mayor who runs it
just came out she's trying her hand at
comedy and she's trying her hand at
comedy
in the name of science to say that she's
assuming joe biden just got elected
president
that science is back
thank god science is back baby
[Music]
and the earth is round
not flat washing your hands
does work social distancing
does matter and wearing a face covering
does help protect all of us
i do love science
[Music]
if that is science give me alchemy
that is if that whatever that is i don't
want that i oppose whatever that is
that of course is not science and those
are not scientists and even our
conception of science is pretty flawed
but that's a politician that's a a
very corrupt chicago politician you ever
notice how all the people who promote
science to us are they're all
politicians
andrew cuomo believe science this lady
believe science
al gore wins a nobel prize for making a
powerpoint about science they're all
politicians isn't that a little weird
the reason for that this goes back to
the earliest days of the progressive
movement
which coincided with the rise of the
social sciences which then fed
data into the administrative state which
took decisions away from the
authentically political realm in our
constitutional system
gave it to so-called experts to make all
our decisions for us and it was all done
in the name of science social science
political science
economic science whatever this kind of
science is
epidemiology all these sorts of sciences
so that you can't disagree with it
right now we're told that we ought to be
able to kill a baby in the womb why
because that's science that's not a baby
it's an embryo
okay well what's the difference well i
don't know but look that's not a baby
it's a fetus well okay do you know what
the word fetus means the word fetus
is latin for offspring it just means
baby okay enough with that etymology
buster
i'm no classist over here i'm a
scientist and what i'm telling you is
that that's a zygote that's not a baby
okay you can
you can keep inventing these kind of
newfangled jargon it doesn't change
the ontological fact that this is a baby
they say no sorry that's science you
gotta kill the babies it is a scientific
fact did you know that men can become
women
science it's just science you say well i
don't know that i don't know that that's
real no
someone in a lab coat told me that they
published it in a journal and it's
it's in the academy believe it that's
not of course none of this is science
these uh scientific statements are meant
to defend policies that people want
namely legal abortion
or a transgender ideology letting men
use the women's changing rooms
something to that effect and that that's
fine but
the reason they they have to pretend
it's sciences so that you can't debate
whenever you hear it's science believe
the signs laurie lightfoot over there in
chicago
science is back what that really means
is there's no more debate
there's no more room to disagree because
we are going to define
all of our views as beyond the realm of
public debate
and you are just going to have to deal
with it these are political questions
some people get that you know i i notice
the conservative politicians
are much less likely to buy into this
kind of game even though it might help
them
in some cases ron desantis over in
florida maybe my favorite governor in
the united states
ron desantis is dealing in political
questions
so there have been some problems around
the country you know when people are
going out and mobbing and looting and
rioting
we are told this doesn't spread the
coronavirus
actually so-called public health experts
told us that it would help
stop the coronavirus to protest white
supremacy i kid you not the 2000 of them
wrote a letter about this
and if you protest white supremacy
because white supremacy exacerbates the
virus it's good
and never mind but but if you go protest
any of the lockdowns or if you go to
church or if you go see your family at
thanksgiving that will spread the virus
that's just science
so let the marauding leftists loot your
stores
burn down your country steal your stuff
break onto your property in st
louis and threaten you with weapons
don't you dare fight back mr mccloskey
that's just science and so ron desantis
came out and he said i think it's a
scientific question i think
it's a political question and i think
i'm going to pass a law that says that
if looters
and rioters come onto your lawn you can
shoot them
that's the law simple law i don't i
can't believe we actually have to make a
law about that
seems to me if people come into my
property if people are destroying
businesses
and then you fight back that's clearly
self-defense defending your life in your
property
but the country has has decayed in in
such a way that people don't see that
anymore so ron desantis taking the lead
here
he's expanding the stand your ground law
uh he
is uh attempting to prevent quote
violent and disorderly assemblies
by permitting violence against anyone
involved in the quote interruption or
impairment of a business
which could include a burglary within
500 feet of
violent or disorderly assembly great
idea this is the kind of leadership we
need
stop deferring to these so-called
experts they're not experts they're just
leftist political activists who are
telling you to shut
up they're they're trying to censor
everybody now and sometimes they'll
outrun lie to do it
getting back to the presidential
election because there are a lot
there's a lot at stake right now in the
presidential election if joe biden pulls
this one out
he's going to empower this bureaucratic
blob the deep state the administrative
state
and all these little experts are going
to write lots of laws well
past the halls of congress they're going
to write it in the epa
or in the fda or wherever and all the
alphabet agencies
to run your life for you and they're
they're going to try to to steal it
if they don't win it outright they'll
try to steal it maybe you heard the
story actually you did because i
mentioned it on the show the other day
the other day postal worker comes out
and alleges fraud
alleges that his supervisor told him
pick up ballots that are illegal
deliver them to me so then the
washington post came out and said
not true this postal worker has recanted
this is fake news
don't spread this story well now
i guess that was supposed to be the end
of the story except that the postal
worker came out and he said
i absolutely did not recant and the
washington post is lying about me
i am right at this very moment looking
at a
article written written by washington
post
says that i uh fabricated the
allegations
of ballot tampering i'm here to say that
i did not recant
my statements that did not happen that's
not what happened
and you will find out tomorrow so we'll
find out he's going to release a longer
video about this
but it didn't happen now i don't i don't
know
the entirety of his story but what i do
know is something that i've known for a
long time
that the washington post is lying about
it the entire establishment press
which is tied into the establishment
academy which is tied into the
establishment
popular culture which is tied into the
establishment technology which is
tied into the established administrative
government and elected politicians
that is what is trying to win this
election it is not about joe biden
joe biden is nothing he is totally
hollow
if you crack him open you would you
would find air leaking out there is
nothing inside he's been an empty suit
his whole career the same goes for
kamala harris
she's she's articulated more forcefully
certain views it's only
because she's younger i think she licks
her finger puts it up in the air
figures out which way the wind is
blowing okay now there
are politicians on the left who have
strong views
they will be pulling the strings joe
biden has already admitted as much he's
moved so radically to the left
just in the issue of abortion he used to
oppose abortion
now he not only doesn't oppose it he
supports taxpayer-funded abortion
with no restrictions there are
these uh strong-minded characters on the
left one of them would be stacy abrams
who is just as much the governor of
georgia as joe biden as the
president-elect
stacey abrams you remember her she's
come out and said forget this moderation
talk
forget this talk about the american
ideals what we need
is identity politics identity politics
is exactly who we are
and it's exactly how we won identity
politics
that's exactly how we won identity
politics that's how
the left went now the trouble of course
with this is the left
didn't just win the election the left
there was supposed to be a blue wave
remember the left was supposed to take
the senate it doesn't look like they did
that
and the left was supposed to win big
seats in the house didn't do that they
lost seats in the house
they may have lost a lot of seats in the
house and they were playing those
identity politics
identity politics is
uh fundamentally opposed to the american
and broader western political tradition
because what identity politics says is
we need to set up essentially a sort of
caste system in america
and we're going to judge people based on
their their
oppression their perceived oppression
whether that's real or imagined and
we're going to give people certain
privileges so for instance we're going
to give
black people certain privileges in
university admissions and
job hiring and they're going to get
those privileges because of the legacy
of slavery
now you might ask what about black
people who do not descend from slaves
like for instance barack obama or kamala
harris
both of whom descended not from slaves
but from slave owners
do they have a disadvantage are they
oppressed
neither of those people seem
particularly oppressed to me one was the
president one might possibly
become the vice president she's a
sitting u.s senator i don't i don't
think
are they how are they oppressed well
because of their identity
not because of the facts of their life
but because of their identity
pits uh americans against one another
and pits all americans
against their own history that's the
point and identity politics
unfortunately is very effective and
what's what's interesting is for all the
talk of white supremacy and white
nationalism these sorts of things white
people in america have a very very low
racial consciousness there was a report
came out i think from pew research
that showed that for every major ethnic
group racial consciousness ranks
above 50 that is more greater than 50
of respondents said that their race is
very important to their identity
uh for black people this was the
strongest followed by
hispanics and asians for white people
racial identity
was 15 way way way way low
which is perfectly fine by me when you
if you were to ask me michael who are
you what are you what would i say
i'm catholic i'm uh american
i'm sicilian you know i get a little
there i got i guess i've got some
english in there
i'm a cigar smoker i'm a joker i'm a
smoker i'm a midnight toker right i'd
give like
and and white guy would be somewhere
pretty far down on the list
but what stacey abrams is saying is no
you're a white guy buddy
white white is number one your racial
identity which
she is constructing for us that has got
to be number one
now that kind of radical politics didn't
win the last election i mean
you say identity politics is how we won
how'd you win the guy that you may be
elected president is the oldest whitest
dude in america right so i i don't if
that's the identity i guess then the
democrats are going back to their roots
but in the future perhaps it will work i
mean there is something to this idea
and michael moore was saying this
democrats need to become socialist they
need to just admit that they're
socialists
stop pretending they're not socialists
and he's been harangued for this but
michael moore
actually gets politics pretty well he
was one of the few people on the left
who called trump and there is a
phenomenon going on right now my friend
spencer clavin over at uh claremont and
the american mind he pointed this out to
me the other day we were discussing the
woke people
and the red-pilled conservatives and the
you know it
the idea that the kind of establishment
consensus on both the left and the right
are cracking
and he said well michael isn't it
interesting that the two terms that
we're using
for people who realize that the old
consensus is broken and that some new
kind of political coalition needs to
form on the left we say they're woke
and on the right we say they're red
pilled
and both terms imply a kind of waking up
out of a
dream-like state waking up and seeing
reality anew
for the first time and i think there's
something to that i think democrats have
behaved like socialists for a very long
time and they just haven't admitted it
to themselves
and i think that conservatives have
convinced themselves of a lot of
sort of slogans and bumper stickers that
aren't necessarily true
and they they they tilt against
windmills and they they
uh fight with they fight battles that no
one really cares about
you know uh it's perfectly fine the
liberal establishment is perfectly fine
to have conservatives arguing for low
taxes sometimes the liberal
establishment doesn't even mind the low
taxes but the minute you bring up
culture the minute you bring up
mass migration the minute you bring up
love of country even all of a sudden
that's a little bit
too much a little too red pilled
now we will find out how this election
turns out pretty soon
before we get into the mailbag there are
some election updates right now we've
found out there will be
a hand recount in the state of georgia
you'll remember on election night trump
was winning georgia
significantly and then you know just
magically in the middle of the night all
those biden votes came in
so here we have georgia secretary of
state brad raffensberger what a name
announcing there will be a by-hand
recount in every
county in georgia the next step in the
current election process is getting the
final county certifications in
we'll then move to the risk limiting
audit or rla
at 1 pm today i will make the official
designation of which race will be the
subject of the rla
at that time i will designate that the
roa
will be the presidential race with the
margin being so close
it will require a full by-hand recount
in each county
this will help build confidence it will
be an audit
a recount and a re-canvas all at once
it will be a heavy lift but we will work
with the counties to get this done in
time
for our state certification many of
these workers will be working plenty of
overtime
we have all worked hard to bring fair
and accurate counts to assure
that the will of the voters is reflected
in the final count
and that every voter will have
confidence in the outcome
wherever whether they're candidate won
or lost
so you heard that term rla rla refers to
risk
limiting audit it's not enough to count
the votes again
if you've got fraudulent votes in there
and you recount the fraudulent votes you
haven't accomplished anything
there are votes in there that maybe
weren't sent in by the people
who said that they were sending them in
there are votes in there that maybe were
not sent in by people who i don't know
are alive there are votes maybe in there
that were sent in by people who aren't
people you know maybe they're the
family's beloved pet or something
we've heard a few stories about that
during this election season we just
don't know
so it's not enough to recount you've got
to audit those votes
usually you're going to hear political
geniuses tell you
that recounts don't matter that much
yeah sure they find fraud there's always
fraud but it's not going to shift the
vote that much
that may be true but we have never had
widespread unsolicited mail-in ballots
we're now talking about what
the numbers that the media are putting
out are 74 million votes for biden
71 72 million votes for trump
those numbers are unprecedented now
maybe it's because of huge voter turnout
maybe it's because there's fraud maybe
there was huge voter turnout but some of
those votes were not eligible we don't
know and so you got to audit
that vote it's not just happening in
georgia we're getting great stories
coming out of arizona now as well
okay there's a lot up in the air there
is a lot that is unsettled
and when things are so up in the air it
helps you to have something very settled
very sturdy
like gold you should check out acre gold
you know
one problem with investing in gold is
that when you invest in gold
you know it's expensive bars of gold are
extremely expensive i i don't unless
you're a bond villain you probably don't
have like bars of gold lying all around
your home
but you can begin to invest in gold
today with acre gold the way they do it
for as low as 30 bucks a month you mail
in
and that goes into your account there at
acre gold and when your account
reaches the cost of that bar of gold
acre gold will ship that physical gold
discreetly to your door it's a it's an
incredible financial product
it is changing the game on investing and
physical gold i
i really like what they're doing uh acre
designs their gold in california sources
their gold from one of the largest mints
in switzerland uh it's great uh
industry-first packaging that looks and
feels more expensive than other
gold alternatives and for me i'm pretty
conservative when it comes to investing
but i have always enjoyed investing
in precious metals so check it out acre
also just recently introduced
their new 100 per month subscription for
their five gram
gold bar you can visit getacregold.com
knowles canada wle s start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url because acre is giving away a
gold bar
what more can i do for you you have the
chance to win a gold bar
to qualify for their giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
of this gold bar at get underscore acre
that is gettiergoal.com
knowles and thank you to aker gold for
supporting the show
so we got the recounts going on in
georgia we've also got new numbers
coming out of arizona so
very quickly before we get to mailbag
joe biden's lead in arizona remember
arizona was called for biden
on election night by the ostensibly
conservative network
now who knows how conservative they are
exactly if they're the first ones
calling arizona for biden
but the trump team has been very
confident from the beginning we are
going to do very very well
in arizona it turns out it looks like
that's correct
joe biden's lead in arizona has now
shrunk below 13 000
after maricopa county dropped some more
ballots
according to data orbital the county's
latest report includes 50
almost 5 300 votes 56.4 going to trump
41.8 going to biden pinault county also
posted some more ballots on tuesday
shows trump taking 63.3 of the almost 1
000 ballots counted there
there remain 46 700 ballots
in arizona 22
400 of them come from maricopa county
maricopa is is pretty decidedly for
trump now president trump needs to take
64
in those remaining ballots in order to
win arizona
that's a high number but it is not
outside the realm of possibility
all pretty good news there and that's
why cnn
is absolutely freaking out we are being
told now
that if president trump does not concede
never mind the recounts never mind the
henry county georgia recounts
counts still going on in arizona the
investigation is going on in
philadelphia never mind all that trump's
got to concede
these demagogues tell us because
otherwise
trump will compromise american national
security
yes or no are the actions that the
president is taking now
putting this country in danger
clearly it's not great for our democracy
let's put some teeth on that if we can
for a moment because there are sitting
members of congress
who were around in their positions at
the time of 9 11.
and the 911 commission specifically
cited the shortened transition
after the 2000 election for having an
impact on national security i'm quoting
here
it hampered the new administration in
identifying recruiting
clear clearing and obtaining senate
confirmation of key
appointees the fact is we have
experience
for how shortened transitions make a
difference
in national security why are we hearing
from
republicans about that granting that
potential danger
yeah why why are these republicans doing
that i mean it's just so awful that
they're compromising national security
i don't remember cnn raising this this
concern
when al gore was dragging the 2000
election out for 38 days based on
nothing by the way based on
absolutely nothing compared to what
we've got now i guess if democrats were
so concerned about this maybe
they should not have refused to allow
republican poll watchers in philadelphia
because if they if they didn't do that
if they didn't illegally
refuse to allow republican poll watchers
and ignore a court order
then maybe we wouldn't have to drag this
out so long maybe they shouldn't have
forced this widespread unsolicited
mail-in ballots
which are vulnerable to fraud maybe they
shouldn't have done that but they did so
unfortunately we're not going to
unilaterally disarm democrats you know
maybe the most scandalizing aspect of
this entire election process
of the whole maybe of 2020 is that you
have
america's enemies around the world
parroting
democratic talking points to attack
america
when you hear china when you hear north
korea when you hear
saudi arabia when you hear russia
talking about the united states
they are parroting democratic talking
points this from the u.n human rights
council
don't you love by the way that china
is on the u.n human rights council china
which kills millions
of their own citizens which forced
sterilization forced abortions
on their own citizens china's on the
human rights council
at the united nations which as i've
mentioned many times before
would make a wonderful luxury trump
apartment building on the east river
for some reason we still have the u.n
standing there but you know i know that
joe biden calls himself the
president-elect he's just as much the
president-elect as i am
and i promise you in the knolls
administration we're getting luxury
condos where the u.n stands
here is what china had to say about the
united states
sounds an awful lot like democrats madam
president the chinese elegant wishes to
recommend to the u.s
one root out the systematic racism
address widespread
police brutality and combat
discrimination against african and
nation americans
second urged politicians to respect
people's rights to life and health
and stop politicizing and uh
stigmatizing code 19 pandemic
three take holistic measures to
eliminate rich poor politicalization and
social inequality
for combat the increasingly severe
religious intolerance and xenophobic
violence
fight stop incarcerating migrants
including migrant children
and guarantee the rights of migrant six
address proliferation of guns and
guaranteed
people's lifetime rights right
throughout
newly uh coercive uh unilateral barriers
and they'd stop torture in uh and uh to
absolutely matter and
hold military intervention in other
countries and stop killing civilians
nine stop interfering for political
reasons in other countries not affects
under the pretext of human rights thank
you madam listening
to that cynical enemy of the united
states
reading the litany of offenses that the
united states is allegedly
committing and not not committing in
reality but is allegedly committing
you would think that that guy were
running for the democratic nomination
for president
and and this is a sad fact about our
politics right now that one cannot
cannot ignore i mentioned this before
the election
the difference in the election is that
trump supporters wave the american flag
and biden supporters burn the american
flag
but michael some biden supporters aren't
burning the flag sure first of all all
the people burning the flag support
biden over trump
but beyond that the people who are
disrespecting the american flag
many more people than who are burning
them the people who won't stand for the
national anthem
the people who will not give reverence
to the flag
star spangled banner they're democrats
they're people who support
joe biden the people who read the 1619
project and say our country is rotten to
the core rotten from the very beginning
they support joe biden
that's a big difference and that to me
is a real national security problem when
you have half the country
that despises the country itself that is
a real security problem
speaking of security it's not just a
political question it's a personal
question as well which is why i've got
to tell you about ring and how much i
love
ring you know ring has been a sponsor of
this show for
years at this point i've given a ring
out to my friends as housewarming gifts
and i'm so excited because i'm moving to
nashville as you you can see i'm not in
my studio right now
i'm kind of halfway out and i'm going to
be in my nashville studio on monday
i've got a great house that i'm going to
be in is in la
you know you can live in a hovel you can
live in a little shoebox or in tennessee
you can like have
acres and acres and just be living in
this beautiful american paradise
and so you know i'm gonna have a have a
house and i'm so excited that i've got
ring sweet little elise is a good shot
but much better
to be able to see hear and speak with
whoever's at your door
from anywhere in the world you can be in
your bedroom you can be at the office
you can be on a beach somewhere across
the globe you can talk to them it's a
really wonderful product
it's a powerful affordable whole home
security system right now get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit ring dot
com slash knowles can wle s
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro that is the perfect way to
start your ring experience
go to ring.com knowlescanwlis that is
ring.com
knowles and while you're on your
internet browser go to dailywire.com and
subscribe
we've talked about some of the awful
things that the establishment media have
done
over just the past week and a half or so
and it's only going to get worse
you've got to replace the media we got a
lot of exciting changes at the daily
wire as i just said we're all moving in
nashville
the other thing that's pretty fun we're
bringing our friend candace owens with
us
we've got an extremely cool show that
we're working on with candace it's gonna
have a live studio audience
i hope to be able to meet many of you
when we do these live audiences
that's always very fun kovid shut us
down well we're not going to take that
anymore
we've got some great cultural work
coming up we're going to be into the
movie business we're going to be into a
whole lot of other businesses
be a part of it join us for all access
that's our elite tier of membership
where you get to hang out with the whole
daily wire community
not just the hosts and the writers but
all of the other elite
all access members something i always
love doing
so much to do and of course you get the
leftist tears tumbler head on over to
dailywire.com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back i'm always running late on
the mailbag so first question from sarah
hello mr knowles
recently my boyfriend and i got in a
fight about me getting a covid test
okay i like where this is going i had
just a stuffy nose and felt like it
wasn't necessary to get one for a few
reasons one i always get a small cold
during the change of seasons yup true
for most of us
two if i went and got a test i would
have had to stay out of work for however
long
it would take for results to come back
which means that i wouldn't get paid for
those days of missing work
three i haven't been in contact with
anyone sick and don't want to get on
some sort of watch list fair enough was
it irresponsible to not get a test or is
kovitz something that has to be accepted
and lived with
any of your thoughts would be
appreciated this is a topic of
frustration
for me and my boyfriend thanks tell your
boyfriend to man
up this is so pathetic it is so pathetic
that you
have to be the voice of reason in in
typically when there are arguments
between boyfriends and girlfriends i
don't want to sound sexist or anything
here
but typically the more emotional
party to that argument tends sometimes
to be
the female part and the men tend to be a
little more grounded but here it's
completely reversed because
because leftism has thrown our culture
upside down
of course you shouldn't have to get a
covid test
because you've got a stuffy nose first
first of all see if you've got the
symptoms of coping
second of all see if you're at risk or
you're around people who are at risk
third of all
you don't need to end your life because
of what amounts to
a very very virulent flu just about
right
especially for people who are in what i
imagine to be your age range
uh second tell your boyfriend if he
wants to boss you around he's got to
become your husband
no don't tell him that that's not that's
not a good way to start a marriage but
tell him to you know grow a spine and
stop living in fear of this virus
be prudent fine don't go you know maybe
don't like go
uh lick your your elderly sick
grandfather okay use some caution here
but you don't need to leave live your
life in constant fear
of a virus that has been extraordinarily
politicized and which by the way is
going to be with us
in perpetuity right that's how these
viruses work the world health
organization estimates and this this is
a month old estimate at this point
world health organization estimates that
one in 10 people on
planet earth have already gotten kovid
on earth
the virus has only been around for
something like 9 or 10 months
we're all going to get it we're going to
get it it's going to be around
maybe there's a vaccine maybe the
vaccine will work maybe people won't
take it it's going to be around have you
ever gotten the flu
do you get the flu shot it's here there
was a study out of chicago showed
one in five chicagoans one in five 20
percent
got coveted within the first you know
nine ten months of it existing
it's going around learn to live with it
tell your boyfriend to stop living in
fear
or get a new boyfriend i don't know i
don't wanna go that far maybe he's a
nice guy but
come on tell him to uh to quote don
corleone when he's talking to johnny
fontaine in his office
you're gonna act like a man what's the
matter with you
from genevieve hacker dear michael for
months now the media has been predicting
that trump will not allow the peaceful
transfer of power
after the election has trump painted
himself into a corner now that he
is by their standards refusing to
concede the election and fulfilling
their predictions
also do you think there's a chance the
courts will rule in favor of biden even
if there is evidence that trump actually
won
just to avoid the inevitable rioting if
they declare trump one thanks love the
show
of course the media painted this picture
they try to do it all the time
you remember they did this in 2016 and
they said there is evidence of russian
interference
russia wants trump to win and then trump
wins and they say
see because we made those predictions
before now we're going to use that as a
predicate to investigate him and try to
stage a coup d'etat on throw him out of
office of course that was the plan the
whole time and they're doing that now
they're saying if trump wins
then it's not democracy you know it's
amazing with democrats so whenever
whenever the people go out and vote and
they don't vote for the democrats that's
not democracy that's a threat to
democracy
but when they go out and they vote for
democrats that is democracy it seems
like
kind of a loaded game who cares what
their standards are i don't care i don't
care what cnn says
i don't care what fox news says for that
matter
you know fox historically has been
better than cnn
but if people are going to push a
narrative
that is politically slanted and untrue
what do i care
it doesn't doesn't affect me at all
there is a legal process in this country
for conducting elections president trump
is engaging in that legal process
and you may well be right there may be a
world in which they uncover lots of
voter fraud but either they can't prove
it because it's very difficult to prove
or they do prove it and the courts go
squishy and say well i just
we don't want to have more riots so
sorry biden's the president that might
happen
that's i guess that's the legal process
we're going to let that legal process
play out i don't
i don't give two wits what cnn says
about it from
from whitney how's that for providence
that's see all nature is but art unknown
to thee
all chance direction which thou canst
not see whitney says michael is a
practicing catholic i am dismayed
by the usccb that's council catholic
bishops
the ringing endorsement of
president-elect
joe biden according to canon law he's
already subject to automatic
excommunication
uh leite sentencia due to his stance on
abortion legislation alone
to say nothing of the legal pressures
put on the faithful by his policies and
those of his political affiliates oh you
mean how he sued nuns
because they wouldn't fund abortion
drugs and already promises to sue nuns
again yeah
yeah that's that's some pressure that's
not very catholic to me
no matter how devout people say that he
is however due to the public nature of
his office and the confusion
his professed catholicism causes the
faithful propriety would suggest that
public and official excommunication is
necessary
as stated in the code of canon law it is
a prescribed medicinal penalty
with the ultimate goal of repentance on
the part of mr biden and reconciliation
with the holy catholic church my my
question is twofold
that was a long introduction to your
question but all good points first
what do you think the chances are of
this happening second what methods would
increase the chances of this happening
it should happen absolutely joe biden is
in a state of grave
sin at the well the sin of supporting
abortion in the way that he is
and the sin of scandal for doing it
that's why he was denied communion
the he was denied the eucharist a church
in i believe north carolina
and no matter what the usccb says
uh joe biden is in a very grave state
and and
support for joe biden and his political
activities
imperils the souls of uh people who
support him
that's just the way it is i once spoke
to a wonderfully erudite priest
and i mentioned my blank book reasons to
vote for democrats a comprehensive guide
and he said michael
i think i'm going to plagiarize you and
title it the wisdom of the u.s council
of catholic bishops
a comprehensive guide and i think it
would be much the same content
uh what are the chances that they are
going to excommunicate him
zero i mean hope springs eternal in the
human rest
but not great and how can we
pressure this to happen i once had
another priest friend of mine
tell me the best way to pressure bishops
is not to write them sternly worded
letters they don't care
not to even you know and there's
something sort of
you can you can publicly criticize and
publicly publicly challenge a bishop
but you don't want to do it in a way
that is disrespectful of the office
because you know we we are
we are governed uh in a particular
structure in the catholic church
but you can of course you can criticize
them i mean you know dante
eligieri put two popes in hell face down
with flames burning the souls of their
feet for eternity so you know you can
make criticisms
however what's more effective stop
giving money to their charities the
bishops have lots of charities
some of which have been used as slush
funds for lots of nefarious activities
don't give them money
i no longer give money to bishops funds
and bishops charities i give to my
church i'll give to other
catholic charities but the ones that are
run by the bishops i don't give to
because
unfortunately the usccb doesn't seem to
serve its flock very well
from julie perhaps a dumb question you
know i was once told by south park that
there are no dumb questions only dumb
people
but i suspect that your question
involves neither of those things
why do we have any reason to believe
that a recount would yield a more honest
vote tally than the original tally
considering the entities that are
storing the ballots are the same
entities that counted the first time
aren't the physical ballots in question
vulnerable to tampering or tossing
between last week and the
reconnectivities yes that's a big worry
this is why you need to audit those
votes it takes much longer but
at least you're seeing georgia do that
hopefully the other places will too the
other issue is
glitches on the voting systems the ones
that are electronic
you you saw this in michigan there was a
glitch that
sent a lot of votes over to joe biden
thousands of them
now this glitch was caught beforehand
but that software is used in 47 counties
so how many other glitches were there
that's another another area that will
need to be audited and i hope that we
have the opportunity to do that
still you know there could be a lot of
issues during the florida recount during
bush v gore
one of the issues was hanging chads so
you would punch the ticket you punched
the ballot
and the chad had to come all the way out
if the chad was hanging
you were not allowed to count that
ballot and so you would have poll
workers you'd see
i was speaking to senator cruz who was
actually a lawyer during the florida
recount
and he was saying you'd see people there
poking poking the chads out
their fingers you know it was this
became a big issue so obviously there
can be some issues during the counting
itself but
the the trump campaign needs to fight as
hard as they can and there are ways to
get at least a more accurate count if
not a perfect count
from bennett good morning michael in
these hectic times i have recently begun
reconnecting with my christian faith i
was raised christian but i'm now
non-denominational
however i've been surprised to find that
in my hiatus
the faith-based online world has been
hijacked by left-leaning mega-churches
who
seem to lack a certain theological depth
who are some conservative voices in the
church that i might find to follow
online
i preferably am looking for churches
that hold true on issues like abortion
and eternal conscious torment
as well as not catering to the whims of
social justice movements like blm
yes i always i too long for those
eternal conscious torments
no i'm joking i'm actually very i'm
pleased to hear that you are taking hell
seriously
people don't take hell seriously at all
anymore and they uh they
imagine a god without wrath leading a
people without sin
into a kingdom without judgment through
the ministrations of a christ without a
cross
not my own words but those of a more
sophisticated theologian
i would recommend my favorite priest
that i recommend you read
and listen to his homilies every week
his father george rutler he's
a friend of mine he's my priest he did
my wedding
and he's just brilliant i think he's
just the most brilliant priest alive
today he's written about a zillion books
that that
that name is george w rutler and you can
i think you can find his homilies on
apple podcasts
strongly recommend him uh who else do i
like
i love patrick madrid he has a daily
radio show on relevant radio it's a
call-in show
it's great he's super smart really
really uh
good to uh you know he's really
accessible
in terms of popular apologetics he's
really smart scott hahn writes a lot of
great books
gosh there's so many uh maybe i'll tweet
a list or something those three are good
to start with though
okay let's see i'll try to take one more
from alexa
michael after listening to your show
today i want to get your take on
something
my boyfriend uh this is this i see a
theme today
and now i feel like i'm going to be
interfering in people's relationships
and i'm going to have some angry
boyfriend come and punch me in the
street somewhere
fortunately i'll be in nashville though
so we'll at least be well armed
back to your question my boyfriend and i
were recently discussing the left
slash mainstream media's outright
dismissal of the lawsuits the trump
campaign filed
in uh several states we're both
attorneys and we found it comical and
frustrating
that the msm's legal analysts have been
preaching that there is no evidence
contained in the trump campaign's
declaratory judgment petitions only
allegations
if we made those arguments to a judge we
would be laughed out of the courtroom
i'd love to hear your thoughts on how
the msm can grossly
misrepresent how litigation and the law
work and get away with it
thanks and love the show they can get
away with it in the
realm of law because they get away with
it with every other realm too
the mainstream media misrepresent
everything everything that is why they
are the fake news
it is not because they don't sometimes
get a story right
it's not because some reporter doesn't
sometimes do something right it's
because
they are not the news they are not doing
what they say that they're doing
drew clavin always brings up this point
where you read the newspaper and you
think oh that's an interesting story
about iraq
oh that's an interesting story about
business taxes
oh that's an interesting story about the
yankees wait a second i know about the
yankees and that story is complete bs
oh well on to the next one and so you
know the one thing you know about
that they're writing but you say that's
not true but then you take their word
for it on so many other issues
this is what happens on law this is what
happens in science right
how how does the msm pontificate about
science and they say one thing one day
they say completely the opposite the
next day
it's because their their goal is not to
talk about science same thing with
politics they get everything about
politics wrong
i you know i hate to brag you know i
hate to say i told you so
i was asked a month before the election
to give my predictions just and i don't
give predictions generally
but it was the end of a long interview
and my friend matt fradd asked me about
this
and i said okay off the top of my head
here's what i think 60 40
chance trump probably gets it but it's
going to be contested and you know
there's going to be this issue where
you're going to have bush v gore times
three or times five and you're getting
recounts in those states and
you know it'll be decided by the courts
right i don't think i'm nostradamus i
just think it
it was pretty clear if you looked at how
the democrats were following the legal
process
and uh nate silver and all the other
genius pollsters in the mainstream media
and the fox news decision desk and cnn
and msm
they all made all these crazy
predictions none of which were true they
were all completely off even if biden
wins they were completely off
because they exist to preserve the
progressive establishment which
increasingly
has not very much to do with reality
we'll see how that legal process plays
out either way i think that system is
coming down
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there